this is the final award this is the gold
medal for narrative filmmaking and and I
believe it's is it raso or is it race el
brazo okay Marc Rosso made his film at
Columbia University in New York it's the
film is called
under again you'll be able to watch this
in its entirety at the conclusion of
tonight's you know awards portion and I
encourage you to do it because this
incredible film about a recovering
addict who who ends up on a trip with
her fiance up in the mountains and they
stop off and and things happen that's
vague I know I'm freaking out I would
like to thank the Academy and I guess
I've heard that said hundreds of times
but for the first time I truly
understand what it means having spent
time with them the past week it's a
wonderful organization that does so much
for filmmaking and this is an honor and
thanks to rich Miller John far and
everyone with the student Academy Awards
for making this possible I speak for all
of the winners here tonight that you
don't know how much this means to us
speaking of family I have to thank my
own family my wife Mehta who supported
me for nine years I'm sorry Ryan but my
mom is pretty much the bomb's as well
she's been you know encouraged me to do
this my whole life and along with my
brother Joseph who helps me at every
step in the way and is a real bouncing
board an honest bouncing board which we
all know we really need my aunt's came
here they surprised me this morning too
flew here to be here with me tonight I
thank them so much I'm from Toronto it's
a long way to come my friends my friends
are here as well as this also one of
impossible without Columbia University
in that experience it's a great great
experience I recommend it to anyone
applying to film schools
you know just a few of the professors
that I have to mention who meant so much
to me hilary brokkr erich mendelsohn
dick prefers and Tom Kalin as well and
last but not least of course the the
crew of under its film is such a
collaborative effort and it wouldn't be
possible without them the producer John
Marcel especially is here my
cinematographer Alan poon is here my
co-writer Jake rain came tonight and
they're just a few of of many many
people who who worked really really hard
to make this happen and the actors I
have to thank Wayne and Zoe for playing
in the snow and Michael for making this
possible thank you